[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the stream
sponsored by samsung i'm cam robinson
and i'm joined by jan from black girl
gamer
hi everybody how are you doing i'm good
good nice to see you again now this is
the final of
our three streams where we are taking
this beast of a tt of tv
sorry the samsung q800t through its
paces
combined with one of the next gen or the
current gen i still haven't figured out
the best way to describe it the new gen
console yeah the xbox series x and what
game are we playing today
we're playing some fifa 21 now what's
your relationship with fifa like
um how long you've been playing i've
been playing for the last couple of
weeks it's been on and off since i was a
kid so i know some of the basics
and then i've just gotten back into this
21 version so yeah nice
well i've been playing fifa probably
more than any other game series but
maybe final fantasy but fifa since i was
a very small child so
i every year it's one i have to play and
today
because i i set up the game we
are going to play a tournament that i've
invented called
euroball 2020 and do you know who we're
going to play as jan
scotland scotland we are yes we're going
to take the scots to victory at euroball
2020 finally
and of course what i'm really excited
about playing fifa on this tv
is because it is so huge it's 65 inches
and it just means that i'm hoping we're
gonna be able to see every single player
exactly where they're running
always be able to see the ball and just
make some really great plays yeah that's
the plan
okay so let's see i think i've already
put on our best
best team so uh yeah should we dive in
yeah let's dive in
okay i'm hungry so abby gets hungry now
um yeah whatever let's just go i'm
pretty sure i already made some changes
to the scotland squad
um so yeah i mean what i think straight
away we should point out that
um today beca um because we got a new
piece of hardware we are actually
it's so good we are watching this right
now in in the studio
at 4k16 now if you were to replicate
this setup at home
you know this tv and the xbox series x i
believe fifa 21 has now been updated to
120 frames and this tv is
completely capable of 120 hertz so you
could play fifa at 120 which is so
exciting
and yeah we're at 4k 60 but not just 4k
one of the most exciting things about
this tv is that it upscales
4k to 8k so we have 8k
fifa right now hold on i will explain
how it does the 8k
when we get the ball oh we haven't got
you in here yeah
where's the blue no i'm playing just me
okay so settings uh side select
yeah so yeah if you come join me on
scotland team there you go
how'd you feel you're scottish already
yeah ready to go get good
um you said you do have some scottish
heritage
one of my surnames is mcintyre so it's
just like um
you know can't ignore it there it is
right there
is that is that because of some or do
you know where the name cut where the
name comes from no
it's literally by the caribbean so okay
it's just
how it is and that's where it comes from
i haven't really traced it that much
here is it in that entire time oh yes
yes come on scotland what do you mean
three minutes into the stream
awesome we haven't been practicing all
day i swear
there you go that's right you punched
that corner flag well done mcgregor
and yeah so uh already i think uh this
this partnership's working quite well
um you say that now oh very nice i mean
it was kind of straight down in the
middle i think that keeper will be a bit
disappointed
yeah um okay so great start at your ball
2020.
um so what i was what i was saying
before about um
so how this tv actually does the 8k it's
pretty cool it's using
something called deep learning
algorithms so it's i think it's a
quantum processor and
um basically the tv is looking every
frame so that frame where you fouled him
nicely it was looking at that frame
and then um predicting and working out
what pixels are missing to make it 8k
what textures it needs to fill in
um all the stuff around the edges still
to recreate this
this image as 8k and uh because of the
size of the tv and everything that's
over
over 33 million pixels on this thing
huge in fact if i look at my notes 33
million
177 600 pixels
wow yeah that's a lot it makes it super
clear like
before we were looking at it you can see
his skin literally give me the ball
go go nice there we go okay so what's
our general tactics here jan like
tactics school score the goals okay are
you fan of a are we counter-attacking
or are we giving them the ball that's
the ball
security we give them the ball they then
put themselves in a bad position
and we then we counter attack take it
there we go there we go
using the new jockey it's new actually
but the jockeying in fifa
oh lovely nice keep running keep running
through ball oh another guy we've got
two mini attackers
oh i think that was now offside god that
does happen sometimes it's like
almost too many players supporting your
attack yeah it's a bit confusing here we
go
[Applause]
how are you enjoying that accident the
migration because i know you've been
playing on playstation
how are you yes i got xbox like when we
say but we say x i'm literally getting
confused
this is confusing yeah press x
this one or that one yeah earlier we
were talking about it was like so when
you press playstation x
you should pass the ball and i don't
know how many of you watching the stream
are like me but
i play alternate controls because there
was a long time when i played
uh privo and that was that was the i
don't know why but that was the control
choice the juror forever
so i do it's funny i it's funny that
we're playing hungary it was just a
random um
kind of mix-up i tend to support a
hungry football because my girlfriend's
hungarian
so yeah so i feel a little bit bad that
we're going to destroy them
in this game but not that oh well you
know you win somebody some
exactly have you been to hungary i have
it's amazing i love you
i love how we always chat a little bit
where we travel
it's good i haven't been i have so okay
little aside
uh budapest and um in hungary the
capital is an
incredible place to visit and once we
can all travel around the world again
you got to go there nice
sorry that was my bad whereabouts in
hungary did you go um
budapest yeah okay well that's that's
where she was growing
she grew up so okay and the the area
around there but it's a nice very
beautiful country
all right but their footballers suck
that was close mcgregor almost got it
through that wasn't that
was not a wise choice it's part of the
reason why i chose scotland
uh if anyone's watching um is because
scotland recently
for the first time in a long time over a
decade
um actually qualified for a pro level
like a top level tournament
wait he hadn't been in the world cup or
the european
cup for uh oh god maybe it's like 20
years
a long long time so big celebrations in
scotland for that
oh no oh i'm lucky
now i should have known how to pronounce
his name because i have been learning a
bit about the alphabet
when you're hungry yeah but i actually
um but then i linked today i was like i
have no idea
on the stream i can't remember i'm sure
i know there'll be definitely someone
watching youtube right
like actually no that's not how you say
it okay
i'm okay all right i'm being greedy oh
sorry oh you've got the ball
oh no no that wasn't my fault i
shouldn't have passed it
got it okay i went to the side nine
very good all right i feel like we are
dominating here
that's a good ball no no no no oh
that was my bad too far too far yeah
it can be quite difficult with the
sprint mechanic especially because
scotland's players players are not the
best players in the game so
they sometimes take a big touch
especially when you're sprinting
so that's so interesting i didn't know
that like i haven't played
thief obviously for a bit in terms of
other games
when he started playing this one
recently so i didn't know that they
still have the kind of stats
still oh yeah they've i mean it's it's
more it's more stat based than it's ever
been really
amazing it's it's more like trying to
tackle you i don't know you just really
want the ball i'll give you the ball
you stand in the good position yeah the
um fifa these days is like
amazing it's exactly what i wanted when
i was a kid because we i used to play
like
football manager game as well like a lot
of people did but this thief is
basically
a football manager game and uh like a
football simulation kind of game oh nice
one you've got it you've got it come on
you yeah yes there we go awesome
so the other teams we have in um
our group is england okay that'd be fun
and i want to say sweden but that might
be wrong i can't remember
uh someone like that definitely england
okay
um all right i'm not sure which
the game half time right uh nearly no 35
we've still got 10 minutes still got 10
minutes
um are you a football fan in general
yeah i used to be an arsenal fan
because i was young um i haven't paid
attention to it
much recently to be honest with you no
me either
i used to really like football and then
oh got it you've got it
yeah and then it was um it was the
olympics it was it was
london 2012 weirdly ruined football for
me
really in a good way because it was
sorry it's a really strange way of
explaining it in a good way
yeah in the sense that um i just
remember during the olympics to be
interviewing all these incredible
athletes and they were just
so pleased to be there to be involved
you know in like
this amazing event and then you turn on
the football
and all these footballers getting paid
like crazy amounts of money you're
always like moaning
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i'm sure
that's not all footballers but that was
the kind of sense at the time
and you compared it to these incredibly
humble incredible athletes
oh that worked oh
yeah and then you compare it to these
amazing athletes who were just so lovely
and humble and happy to be there
i was just like yeah yeah i don't like
you anymore football
but i've kind of been getting back into
it ever since lester had that amazing
season a few years ago
i am where was i at 20 i think i was in
barbados
2012 olympics ah okay yeah
i remember them saying that it was um
that year it was
hotter um london was hotter than
barbados at that point
because of the heat in the city and the
buildings um oh wow okay
so it was it was super hot that yeah i
bet um barbados was
still nicer yeah definitely definitely
would not trade it
now one of the um the other things that
we're experiencing right now
while playing fifa thanks to this setup
we've got here
it's not just related to the tv though
but um what the tv has is something
called
um object tracking sound plus so what
that means
you can't really see them but looking at
the tv along the side along the top
there's a whole this is like a big line
of speakers so while we play the game
actually if i get us back into the game
we're winning that's the story of the
half
back in yeah so while we play um
because the speaker's all the way along
as as they can it basically tracks
the um the action that we're seeing on
screen yeah so the sound
like moves along with the action so it
can have a really cool effect and
because we've also got it
plugged into the sound bar there which
is the
q900t soundbar um
the really cool thing is normally when
you plug into into a soundbar directly
it kind of just stops the tv speakers
functioning but these actually
function together and i was miles
offside sorry
miles i would i will lie if i pretend
that i know the offside will say
it's all right fifa knows the offside
rules yeah right the game knows
all right commitment to the cars
i'm not sure i'm tackling correctly oh
that's all right so tackling
in fifa 21 is is kind of tricky the best
thing is just to hold left trigger which
is the jockey button
oh lovely pass though get it
oh great girl well done
nice to see you great yeah that was
awesome
um yeah the i do think the the attacking
is easier in this game than defending
but yeah it's
jockeying with the left trigger or lt's
in this pad
but then your two tackles are on x and b
so for you because you're the regular
controls
b will be i can like standing tackle
that's the one
but you can still follow people with
that and quite easily
and then x is your sliding tackle which
is even easier to bow yeah
it's really easy to give away penalties
if you use those buttons but you know
sometimes you have to in order to get
the ball but i think generally jockeying
is usually enough
oh yes come on
[Applause]
i literally pressed it i don't know he
almost looked like he tried to pass
i know but i pressed b that's the right
one yeah yeah you know it was a shot he
just uh
he's just rubbish at it also i i love
the ball that we've got
i
like that's incredible brilliant
all right okay i think we're i think we
might have won this one
yeah i think i think we're doing quite
well just let's just see at home
i feel like a fifa amateur who hasn't
played in
only been playing for the last couple of
weeks oh he's doing great
um yeah this way okay
all right oh yeah nice
so um i mean do you know how to do one
twos
once you pass let me hold hold l1 and
then press pass and it means uh
your character will run forward and
anticipating a pass forward nice
okay all right got it
i was greedy there sorry ball greedy
stolen absolutely
he's yours oh okay that was good so that
there was just that was your standing
tackle
yeah it's not oh
keep that clean sheet nice that's it
let's go cam
yeah keep running up the side i'm going
to give it to you there e i'm trying
okay
i'm going to okay i'm going to lob this
over to you there you go
so that pass is l one and and y oh
you're awesome
sorry yeah that's a really good pass is
like the the lob through ball so if you
hold l1 is generally like
a modifier button for your passing oh
that's so close
yeah and then you hit y which is through
ball it's just like an aerial one
um which is quite good for putting over
the head over the ball
yeah so it's just again it's just a
variation of that
it's so cool because i didn't realize
how technical fifa was yeah it is
there's a lot to it but it's also you
don't need to know
everything if you put it on like it's
just like a lower difficulty you can
just kind of pick up
as long as you notice sprint and pass
and shoot you can still
you can still play i don't know why he's
on this his character just running
around
no it's right keep going oh yeah yeah
hold hold left trigger
because yeah cause left trigger even
when you're uh even when you have the
ball you can like shield it it's
basically
it's your defense it's your b strong
button um you got it now it's yours
all yours no it's not oh it was
so you think will you be watching uh i
mean obviously euroball as well
yeah will you be watching the um the
actual european uh cup next year it's
gonna be next year now obviously
maybe it depends who's in it i think
scotland obviously
i think i mean i'll watch for you cam
there you go
all right i'm going to try and get this
to you again
open yeah oh that was so close
that's so close yeah hungary is probably
going to be the easiest game we have
so i'm glad to see that we're winning it
because uh it would be ashamed we seem
to lose our first game
because the aim is to get to the final
in this stream you know that's the aim
is to win
all right we'll get you all 20 20. i may
have to make the games a bit quicker
because we need people to actually it's
taking longer tonight to speed
we need to be people um have people
rooting for us because i will not do
well without
any all right i'm going to turn across
this to you
oh it's a oh backwards you got it you've
got it
good goalkeeper literally about
give me oh whoops
nice okay here we go i'm gonna i'm gonna
have a stupid oh no i'm not gonna pass
it
i was gonna be greedy but oh
what was that finish you did it was i
know i'm saying
no probably not i was sure that was
upside down we did it
i loved how pitiful his job was yeah
so nonchalant
let's watch that again uh i was not
offside
oh i guess i was behind behind my own
player
behind the ball yeah okay
uh just a little just a little tap just
a little smidge
yeah nice nice there we go pretty
decisive
yeah maybe we're on two easy difficult
level i think we're on semi pro which is
like the
default difficulty okay yeah so we
didn't crank it all the way down no i
think we should keep it up
and amateur beneath that so
let's not get too confident confident
yeah this is
just hungry after all no offense hungry
i'm sure all the offense was taken i'm
sure it was
oh let's make a substitute yeah gonna i
like this about fifa um
21 is now got this substitute suggestion
so this little thing appears it's not
always the best choice i will say
um but it's like if your players are
getting really knackered um
rather than you having to go into the
menu and make a choice i'll be able to
do it for you well it's like maybe you
want to
sub this guy okay and seeing as we're
four and all up i'm like yeah
probably good might as well may as well
whenever you say computer
we'll take your we'll take your advice
okay
fancy footwork a little bit a little bit
back inside
oh oh oh we didn't mean that that was an
accident
i meant the guy is down there yes some
it's very yeah sometimes
yeah you just passwords never quite go
it's always a crucial moment
yeah i will just not go to the person
you meet
paul's like no let's go the other way
here you go
nice very good coming back to you if i
can oh
quick come on finish it oh no no you
take it
oh i think i was offside
we almost oh that was good with this guy
whatever you say armstrong on
i must say although um i was very
excited about
scotland qualifying i i don't i haven't
watched it from
scotland play football for a few years
so i actually have no clue about this
team or who they are
yeah but i'm gonna i'll learn that
one last chance oof nice oh
[Music]
for a minute they were going on like a
little a well-oiled machine
[Music]
so you can do like some skills on there
with the uh right
yeah this player is our best player
actually that guy the right back he's
scotland's best player by long layer
there we go oh
nice oh this is for you this is for you
keep running
oh okay no that was my bed is that
offside as well
yeah in those positions you can just
keep running if you hold
yeah and if it looks like they're gonna
attack you if you hold left trigger to
like jockey them back
you might you might get through
sometimes they'll attack you sometimes
you get through all right
oh okay well pretty decisive victory
i think we've done quite well i'm quite
proud i don't think um
i wasn't suspecting this yeah
[Laughter]
yeah we've really uh we've really showed
these show these hungarians okay um
here come on it's over ref you can blow
the whistle now
i know right we're just holding the ball
well
i kind of did some skill there a bit
kind of beat my own player oh yeah
the right stick is quite good actually
for just like jinking inside people
oh okay he's gonna go all the way gonna
go all the way
there we go well played yeah
well done yeah not a bad start okay
scotland
can already see the euro ball 2020. euro
ball 2020.
yeah it does yeah it does sound like a
lottery thing isn't it it does it sounds
like a lottery oops
uh okay uh advance so when we get in the
next game there's actually
i thought that we might need some tips
after the first game
apparently we don't but i'm going to
show you a really cool functionality
that tv can do
uh during this gaming is england so
let's jump in
okay and actually just before we do
let's see if any of our players
need i don't know because i thought they
might be knackered but
oh you know what i didn't actually even
put our best team on
this guy's 75 but this
i can't remember this guy scored oh well
he's getting subbed anyway
chuck him in yeah we'll just put him on
the bench uh
yeah and then this guy should really be
on as well
because yeah this so the number um
yeah it kind of yeah it shows their
ability basically
um so we've got a few good people i
think that's our best team though
yeah i'll trust you on that let's say
but yeah this guy's our best like 87
he's very good
i'll trust you i'm uh not the football
um i used to be it's so funny when i was
young i really used to be
went to the arsenal stadium had the bag
and everything really
it was my school bag so you went to some
games as well
no all right
for the longest time and then recently
i did a journalism foundation journalism
course in women's
sport um and uh
i learned a lot more about football
during that as well not just as like a
consumer but like people who write about
it go to the matches and stuff like that
it was really cool
and we watched some of the women's uh
football matches
nice who was playing i don't remember
[Applause]
was it the arsenal women's team am i in
this yeah yeah you're red
oh no wait i'm red no you're red sorry
blue right here it's just me why why is
it just me
again i think we have to do this every
game then okay
i didn't know that oh no no no no
yeah you could be england if you like no
no no i'm good i don't want to be back
you're going to want
me i know this for a fact okay here we
go
uh yeah you're blue then right so i will
pass this to you now
there you go oh yeah so one of the
things we can try
while we play now is um so this the
samsung q800t
also has a multi-view setting okay um
so let's say we're playing fifa i mean i
think oh yeah it's my free kick sorry
i'm going to lob this in
um so let's say we're playing fifa now
and we oh i didn't love it at all oh
that was you
that was me was it you i thought it was
you but i pressed the button oh
wait am i red i'm so confused now yeah
you're right i'm red
yeah so um you want to kind of love
those ones in with that i didn't realize
it was
with square i mean x no
it's in this one okay the x on the xbox
pad
that's it yeah um yeah
and that'll be a long throw wait is it
me oh that's me
i'm so confused now why am i so confused
okay england's going to be a bit
trickier yeah they're skilled
what was what i was going to say about
the multiview is let's say we
were struggling with fifa and we wanted
tips on
tips on how to score or how to um
you know defend better or whatever um
what you can do
it's going to pause it now if you grab a
phone
where did i put the phone here it is if
i grab my iphone in this case it works
on android as well
i'm just going to unlock the phone uh
here we go
okay so let's say we're losing we need
some tips all you need to do on your
phone is go
to the screen mirroring yeah and then
browse for the tv here it is samsung
q800
what it will do is you then see your
phone and now if we tap away from this
go into youtube and here we have our
youtube video
that is going to be awesome right next
to
our next story game of fifa so you could
be like all right you know what i'm
going to see some tips
some good skills going on here um and
you can also customize a really cool
thing if we grab the tv remote
which i've also hidden um
we can choose if i press down and go
over to screen size
we can choose the layout that's awesome
so you might be like ah you know what
maybe
maybe you want to watch someone else
play it like maybe someone's live
streaming if you phone you want to keep
track of their game but you also want to
play your game
that's so cool you could do that you
could watch them streaming on youtube
while you play yours or you know if you
really wanted to i suppose you could
um the other way around or you can
actually do a picture in picture so
let's say we want them in
the bottom left of the screen awesome
and um so yeah we can we can literally
play while that's playing just just by
point of my point of proof so if i
resume the match you ready
yeah sorry my bad just got caught up in
the watching naturally
we can continue i mean it's kind of in
the way of part of our screen we
probably want the top right to be honest
yeah it works is the point and um
all you need to do is you can select as
long as you select whichever one you
want to have the sound
um yeah it's that easy
it's so good for like walkthroughs and
you know when you play rpgs and you're
just like stuck in a place
and you can't figure out a puzzle or
something yeah that is so cool
and yeah you could do it this way round
you have the youtube bigger and your
game smaller
yeah and then if you're if you're done
you can just disconnect on the phone so
i'll just do that
uh oh i locked it first
just unlock the phone it's not actually
my phone which is why
i have to enter the code come on phone
okay the phone doesn't want to unlock
uh why it's not unlocking no it's
here we go i think it already was
unlocked there you go stop mirroring
and now we should be back again
it's going to be so smooth as well yeah
basically really simple
that's the thing i was worried it was
gonna be like a big delay or anything
but very quick
and then you can be back into your game
so if we
find ourselves losing we may have to do
that okay let's get some tips
um well i think i had played him
you did but it's all right you go with
it yes great tackle
okay come on scottish counter attack
here we go
i'm coming in as well
oh lovely get you get it in oh
save all right your ball yours no oh oh
oh is that a shot i like it
it's a bit tenacious i'm a bit too
tenacious like any angle
i will shoot any position
a bit too tenacious there that's right
that's how we're gonna win
um okay
mine oh
[Music]
sorry you're off side so i can't pass
but i'll try and make space oh
oh i didn't feel like that's not worried
yeah if you go past the last offender oh
oh shoot okay so this is where football
knowledge does come in handy because i
don't know
i actually just timed it's really it's
my responsibility as a person with the
ball to like
time the pass the perfect moment to pass
it
[Applause]
who are you passing to your man it was
like kind of a clearance but uh
that's right
yeah william this is i love this
is surrounding him it's like high school
football everyone run at the ball
come on oh sorry that was my fault right
got it did i get it i kind of got it you
guys
come on no no
yeah they're tougher they're much
tougher than yeah they are
nothing
oh yes okay so i think they've got a
corner it's okay
you can clear it now right oh no it's a
goalkeeper all right guess it buy stuff
in
all right what's the plan big kick small
big kick big kick okay
all right try to head across no he got
it
got it oh i'm gonna try and tackle this
out there we go
that's a corner okay so yeah just to
just hammer uh i guess b for you
yeah terrible corner thanks england
oh okay uh oh the goalkeeper
he's trying to scare him oh tackle him
um i have a question go for it
so is the squee screen that's the screen
mirroring capability available on the
q9t as well
um i believe it is yes okay so
that excuse me that's the tvs behind
us yep which i should have mentioned so
thank you for reminding me yeah so the
tvs behind us are
um the q90t which has pretty much all
the same functionality functionality as
the q800c
except it's 4k tv and they are
55 inch i believe i say 65 inch 55 inch
so not quite as big but um yeah they do
they i believe they have a screen
rearing as well
i'm sure they do the job they're still
huge i almost said screen as well
yeah yeah screen i don't
we need to get this first goal come on
we got four last time we should be able
to no
oh referee come on yes
so harry kane that's a classic striker's
challenge that is
all right so i think just a little a
little a pass here then you'll pass it
straight to
my guy there yeah i often think that's
this way
yeah then you can create your attack as
you like oh yeah nice oh
such a good first touch oh oh yeah good
get in
oh it's hard to get the batman yeah yeah
they've got a lot of them
what's that one they seem to get loads
of people back
in the way of our shots ah there we go
i'll tell you it's happening he
genuinely looks surprised yeah okay i'm
gonna pass this because
my guys were waiting he wasn't really
printed at you
yeah nice that's good oh okay i'm gonna
have to
have to slow down a bit i wasn't gonna
get past him can't just run past him
like dude he's hungry
oh yeah nice nice come on take a shot
yes come on yes great goal nice one we
did
i was wondering when they released fifa
21 if they were going to do like
a corbid mode with no fans yeah it's
this year
you know like are they going to have
that but no that's so yeah i guess that
might be strange
oh that's a lovely finish but yeah so
you still get your full
stadium of fans in people 21.
i really want this ball now apparently
it's so i thought it was like some crazy
custom one apparently that's the
champions league because i looked when
we loaded in there
at the beginning it i noticed that the
uefa champions league
slogan on it so that might be an
official champions league maybe i don't
know for sure
all right that's a great time to score
just before half time
their team talks gonna have to be
completely rewritten
and i've stolen the ball from him all
right
oh referee foul come on
[Applause]
sorry i keep skipping the uh the replays
i'm just so that's like
without even thinking about it i always
do that on fifa i'm like nope jump get
better
yeah this is you right because i am so
bad for these free kicks
i i've never managed to score running in
521 i understand
roughly how like what you're meant to do
i think what i might do is actually lob
it in
um this might not work so oh i left it
too long
well i see it was good what what oh get
it get it
no straightens the ends yeah i
seen that was upside down
yep oh that was so close
that was so close
all right let's just not concede until
half time and then that will be a
job done in the first half
we switched to you so we've obviously
we've turned the commentary off oh no
oh great block yeah if anyone's
wondering why there's no commentary we
just turn it off because we're streaming
and
otherwise we'd be like in battle with
them speaking
um but the commentary is pretty good
obviously really yeah yeah i feel like
it's an improvement on previous years um
playing quite a lot of 521 and
previously i always started fifa games
the commentary
would get really repetitive because yeah
the same same voice lines
yeah exactly um but i feel like they've
they've got even more variety in 21
it's quite cool when you're doing like
the career modes and stuff and if you
sign a new player
you're like oh it's this it's just it's
just debut today
and it's quite fun
yeah it really is like an rpg like the
future it is definitely
it's like i think i can imagine football
fans everywhere really love it because
they get to really live the game
yeah totally they need to sign all their
favorite players well
yeah if he goes a team which has any
money unfortunately there's no mode to
be like
purchased by a russian oligarch like
that's not something yeah that happens
okay so yeah it's half time time's gone
yeah
um so i'm thinking we might
need to quicken up the matches yeah
increase the so you know what i'm gonna
do right
if we jump into the settings um we can
game settings i believe we can change it
here um
so that's camera visual or
you know what we can do here we have to
after this game so what is this game we
can change the half length
of the game yeah um anyway that's cool
no problem just quicker games just so we
make sure we can get to the final yeah i
want to get to the final see if we win
yeah assuming we qualify but if we win
this oh
very angry yeah yeah he was not happy
about that
yeah i always i always put a guy in the
line there because um
frequently that's exactly where they put
it
normally nice play okay let's get a
second goal down the side
oh okay fair enough straight to the
striker all yours
oh i'm looking i'm sure that was in his
face i did look like it
he is dazing cool guy
oh they do love to clear it it's just
completely fast though always we kept it
in
how amazing that didn't look like it was
gonna stay in no but he's lost the ball
now
and now it's your turn come on counter
attack here we go
ready get ahead get ahead your head
dammit no you're not oh
you didn't pass
me sliding behind it yes give me the
ball that's always how i went i am
i would be the worst football player
ever
you'll be slight tackling everyone all
right i'm going to throw a seat
this guy here oh cheeky little flick
there
very nice i'm learning
oh no no yes yes
very nice i am so surprised
i did not expect that yeah they just
kind of let you run past them a bit
because they did right they were quite
aggressive before so i'm getting used to
how aggressive they are and they just
laid back for a bit i guess your guy was
really sprinting fast
let's see oh
he kind of tackled at the wrong time
yeah that was bad defending but great
shot
yay okay two nil yeah that's it
see this one over the line the other
thing you can do actually inside fifa
i'll just show you because i'm not sure
if you've seen this yet but you can go
if you can jump to sim
dory we can come back out of it but you
can then like have the computer
play and you can do more like a manager
simulation but then at any any point you
can just hit hit
x and jump back into the game it's so
cool
yeah what you can also do as well is you
can you can jump to results and it will
like
based on the player's stats and
everything or like simulate the result
from that point
so say you're you're winning massively
and you're like oh i'm pretty sure we've
got this
and i want to get to the next game you
kind of just sim it to the end but
there's always the risk
you know the the computer has like a
massive comeback while you put it on the
sim oh
okay see you again come on griffin
get it come go go go go oh
that was nice damn all right i think
you've converted me
yeah you're enjoying it oh my gosh what
is it surprise fifa fans
yeah you just need to um convert your
boyfriend there as well right
him playing as well lord you can do uh
yeah i mean my brother used to do that
we did convert people
no no no no lord and save your fifa 20
years we'd have like we'd play fifa
together and we'd have like a league you
know where we dad oh that's so cute yeah
yeah
we used to live together and kids oh i'm
looking for the pass
you know what they're standing off i'm
going to shoot oh
not very challenging
you got it okay yeah yeah i think we
definitely speed the games up because
that's
that should be long enough now yeah yeah
um
not a problem
okay playing it in
it's just uh we can take it we can
afford to take it
kind of easy you know over expose
ourselves oh that's good that's good
no no oh yeah keep running keep running
it's a huge gap why are they not closing
it down
no oh i don't know why he did it like
that that was a poor shot yeah we that
we should be three nil up
i'm now maybe i'm going over the top
here but i think next game
we should reduce the length of the
halves
see ransom weirdly yeah we should reduce
the length
of the halves but also increase the
difficulty
i think we should we're winning two nil
yeah but it's england come on
it's should be three now that's okay
yeah sorry we're doing well i think we
can handle it i don't i don't want
any complaints cam if not
i think i just think we're good enough
for the next one
[Applause]
oh that's oh i missed i lost control
that was my bird that's right
i was gonna pass that on so i think
we've got a few tired legs out there
uh maybe we should do some some
something yeah so that'll just a little
bit of stubby
so yeah we can do them manually like by
jumping in
you can see they're kind of yeah they're
exhausting bars so this guy's knackered
mcgregor
you see the worst stamina come on come
on mcgregor
i thought you're a professional
footballer right train right well threw
christie on and then
we've got one more sub took this
armstrong guy on because
forrest's looking quite tired and then
our striker's looking tired too
oh yeah tommy oh yeah mcdonald's
knackered oh we're at subs oh well
all right sorry guys tommy you're just
gonna have to keep on running
rest when you're dead all right come on
okay oh oh okay yes
all right counter attack you're down the
wing
what nice that was a great pass okay but
i didn't intend that
yeah it's a good one though oh lovely
he's on side
oh he's outside oh
didn't even oh yeah that was very close
yeah he was but
not much not too much
oh they're making subs oh no there are
subs
of course these haven't happened yet you
got that yeah
[Music]
that's weird seeing crowds i was going
to say the crowds and fifa
always crack me up yeah it's just like
the repeated animation yes yes
they see like in that crowd there'll be
like five people doing exactly
the same thing yeah yeah i know
it's come a long way for me it was just
like an a flat image oh wow this is a
real chance
oh put that one in for a minute yeah
he did some uh some sort of finesse shot
or something i don't know i think he
just sliced it
yeah silly moo oh well
oh quite close to the close oh risky
play
by england that's okay though
yeah they haven't really managed to
threaten have they
they've done quite a good job of
stopping them
yeah here we go
[Music]
nice i thought i fouled him but
apparently not okay
he kind of made him have a stronger pass
than that but nevermind
lovely okay and
oh terrible pass all right all right no
i did that
i you know what that that registered
from when i pressed it earlier yeah yeah
yeah as
opposed to doing what i actually wanted
it to do it's all right the keeper had
it
had it covered no problem
all right that's another victory i think
that we can safely say yep
oh it's your ball oh it's my ball okay
well you know when it comes
all right so we get one more oh oh wow i
like now they don't like that
that's fun that's fun too tenacious yeah
that's not a problem
okay are you good
oh you know what i think um i think i
might have
played you offside yeah well just very
like very lucky
you know what it's very easy to see how
offside he is on this giant tv isn't it
not a good one but no i think um i don't
know about you but
because i've had played fifa for so many
years yes it's definitely
the biggest tv i've ever played on not
just the biggest but like having that
resolution
helps so much so if you if it didn't
catch me seeing earlier this is the
samsung q800t
um so it's 65 inches i said earlier
and um we're playing this in upscaled 8k
which is the most case i've ever played
through them
you can see the skins and you can
literally see the pores on
john mc again john mcginnis
i should really know how to say that
john mcginn's face um
yeah it's uh it's really it's my
this is the only way i want to play
through tonight where i can actually see
everything i can imagine trying to go
back to like
yeah level resolution well before before
last year i was playing on the switch
now don't get me wrong i love the switch
great console but like the look and the
sweat it's uh
the screen is like when you play it in
handheld mode at 720p
yeah so to give you an idea of how many
more pixels are going on here
this is so we think about well my tv at
home is 1080p
right yeah that's kind of like um what
do we call it so with 720
uh sorry is hd and then um
anyway 1080p this is nine
times that so you can put nine 1080ps
into this display yeah which is that's
crazy sorry sorry not nine i lied
16 16 16 1080 ps into the screen
so yeah obviously it wasn't mine it's
crazy yeah so it's uh
it's it's huge and it's full hd
definitely
it's so much so much more than full hd
yeah it's really good
i really think they should have bought
their naming conventions for hd better
you know because it was like first it
was hd which was just 720. yeah
and then it was full hd yes and then
uhd which is 4k what are they going to
call 8k do we know
xhd could you imagine yeah i don't know
why i just you know when sometimes
it probably is one x yeah just a free
edgy
yeah like of course that's the next
convention xhd
all right so two wins two and feeling
pretty good
so we see who else is in our group i
can't even remember i just saw germany
oh it's spain well currently scotland
top of the group uh you can see i like
the stuff because you can see
who's who's the top scorers you know uh
command of france
ronaldo portugal yeah and um
oh you get the news so russia defeat
rivals one nil
i like begin goal seals england defeat
yeah it's kind of cool
uh all right let's change the settings
like i said the same time yeah
let's put half length out of four yep
and difficulty up to professional
are you feeling professional i think you
are yeah okay i believe
yeah i'm gonna let you i'm gonna let you
answer that because i'm gonna play one
of the best teams in the game that's fun
like i know spain spain loves football
just as much as england oh yes it does
but i think we are are we through
regardless no we're not because if
england beat hungary
and spain beat us it'll come down let's
have a look at the goal difference
well we haven't conceded a goal so i
think even if we lose this game against
spain we'll probably go through
okay so well let's find out why don't
you put us up to professional
so we're fine what we get okay
estadio santiago oh it's gone
euro ball 2020. i love how you can oh
yeah i don't know did i mention you can
because this is a custom tournament in
fifa you can name your tournament
whatever you like and you can put
whatever teams you like in it
we just decided to do oh wait hold up
i'm not in here oh yeah it's just me
every time every time um settings we're
in our away
kit as well this time i think or
alternative kit there you go
all right yes
basically what it's saying there is um
that we don't get our
achievements if we're should we have an
extra pair but we don't mind
we're not in it for the achievement for
the glory
and the goals and scotland and scotland
scotland exactly i'm not very good at
doing schools that wasn't that bad
i've definitely heard worse heavy
got it get it all right oh yeah that
sounded a little overzealous but that's
fine
pre i think when i press the button
sometimes i press it in advance and then
the character switches and it still
registers yeah action
that definitely happens that's been a
trait of fifa
from forever you'll be like hammering
past and then you're like wait no i want
to shoot there yeah i need passes
because obviously you press pass
oh hello keith oh good tackling you put
this on professional you did
it's all right it's all right i think i
think you can still do this okay
he's there i'm gonna need some extras
all right it's all right
just remember the uh remember the jockey
for tackling
it's going to be at the back where we're
going to notice this we're still going
to score goals but we might
concede some now it's definitely going
to be more difficult
this guy is better
it looks like you just went to the
corner shop exactly
oh short corner
oh all right he's well he's running the
wrong way which i'm okay with oh no no
he's running back this way
professional and now freezing freezer
has got the ball
come on let's go fraser is literally my
middle name
really yeah oh no you're offside sorry
am i i should have held on the
yeah except for some reason mine's with
a zed oh yeah
oh damn it miles off because i'm one
yeah
over eager there all right
okay
[Applause]
all right we're gonna i think we can
just contain this guy over here
there's also a button that i don't
really use very much but can be useful
in fifa is if you when you're defending
like this oh very nice
nice oh very okay
oh wait yeah that was me sorry i thought
it was you
just because i previously had the ball
that's right you got it oh i didn't i
tried i get it we'll get it
oh no okay just lock him so you catch it
yeah yeah
nice all right cool um yeah what you can
do when you're defending is if you hold
down
r1 yeah uh other ai controlled teammates
will kind of start to come over yeah
that said call over i didn't really
entertain the person it doesn't always
work i can't and you got to be careful
because it pulls them out of position
they can be quite good they're basically
bullying yeah basically bullying which
we're all about
[Applause]
[Music]
yes of course yeah sure why not
don't don't go and bully kids
okay i'm back here for now i'm trying
yeah i got you
oh i don't know what to do
come on yes oh you're off side of it
no yeah like he looks like he's
complaining yeah just disallowed goal i
think
i hate oh come on i hate it
here i did wonder how you said they're
not even going to show us the replay
they're just like don't be stupid
it's all right we can we can have a look
at the instant replay function i hate it
here let's have a look how do i rewind
more
okay so yeah the shot came in here
and yes you guys miles outside
all right wait hold on wait a second
offside sir i'm not supposed to be ahead
of you lot
yeah so you need to be behind um either
the ball
or the the furthest back opposing
defender
so yeah you're like you see the distance
between the big
there's a big gap there i think that's
how you describe it okay so you're
saying because this is nice
i know yeah you successfully explained
the offside rules i mean like two
minutes
and i've been trying to understand it my
whole life all thanks to fifa 21
and the samsung q800t that's fine
combined
it can teach the outside room okay
right in front of the referee as well
he's just having none of it
get up
nice come on no no no no
keep saying no okay that's right just
safety throwing
this is definitely harder on
professional that's all right we're not
losing
we're not winning either not yet but
take your time we'll get there
really coaching me through this
experience don't worry have confidence
it's going to close them down there we
go yeah take that all right all right
keep running keep running that's you
that's you
yeah no sorry i meant like running up
don't worry i've learned i'm red again
all right this is a great this is a
great chance let me move back here we go
yes you've turned him oh
you turned him so nice that's right it's
right i don't want to be i was trying
i'm trying to make this guy down here to
run up the wing
finally he runs up the wing oh too late
usually ai is pretty good at making
those runs but sometimes you'll be like
dude what are you doing it's a huge
space
just run
oh yes come on you got it all right
good oh he's miles outside again he's on
the side there nice
coming inside bringing it in bringing
the bullet okay
oh two people oh come on last time we
were attacking
yeah it's okay interesting half
no i think it's all right the fact that
we've that we're nil nail against one of
the best teams in the game
um and we we've scored six goals already
in the previous games i think i think
we're going to be fine
okay um all right let's keep ours it's
working for us
all right okay
where you going are you going to beat
the whole team that one
oh this guy i think this guy's good
enough he can just have little skills
he's actually
he's quite fast on the ball it's forest
nice nice
oh oh no oh dear oh dear
that's right bad day by day by day okay
just uh
keep keep calm track your guys oh
yes trying to bully him keep this key
yes
mctominy comes to the rescue okay here's
there's the ball oh right down the side
oh okay
we're down in the middle no that works
too that was good down the side
the overlap lovely okay i'm gonna cross
this into you
time for a heady goal we haven't had one
yet okay that wasn't quite what i meant
that wasn't anywhere near his head i
literally
i don't know why that was such a huge
cross but fair enough
i guess he knew what he was doing oh
risky it's all right
i don't know how many penalties we
wanted to go in this thing
yeah yeah here we go
there you go okay i'm trying to become a
guy in the middle
oh lovely nice
i'm in the middle oh
that was so close bender just got split
on the ball
oh god damn all right
oh come on
uh oh dangerous danger danger danger
stranger come on
[Applause]
uh there's the penalty oh god
mckenna he literally went like this
because you you kind of have you already
kind of tackled him
and you're like i've talked with you
stranger danger it was brilliant sorry
okay oh god okay let's uh
blue that's you right you're a
goalkeeper oh
i didn't give you much chance they did i
didn't even know yeah so to dive use the
right stick you just push the direction
yeah i definitely didn't use that
that's right don't worry well uh let's
unless england are being hungry like six
mil
which i don't think they are we should
be okay
sergio although let's let's uh make a
little change up front
bring on our different striker okay
cause why not because we can
uh or no we'll bring on this he looks
tired
frasier yeah he's been quite good though
i might bring on this
actually you know what i'm just going to
bring on on this guy
at the right back because that guy's not
very good yeah and he was also tired
all right here we go uh it's time time
to
i promise i won't beat anybody else up
he got it coming
how dare he be in our box with the ball
oh boy okay it's this serious thief in
there we need to
need to come back seriously
that's good almost almost all right
is she trying to chase this i know
sometimes people's like that you're just
like
oh no no no no no no no oh
it's safe so fast
i love him calm down it's just a
commercial
all right yes no no
yes miss rubbish i've had three attempts
though
no no this is definitely harder and
professional
but i think we can still come back from
this i have confidence
what's that yellow bit on top of my
thing um you've got a yellow card i
think
that's the case the guy was booked here
oh
what ma'am okay okay safety that's fine
i think i'd run off side so that was
actually a good a good move
okay uh trying to find the gap for the
pass yes
oh lovely get it that's such a good girl
amazing that little back heel that was
great
yes go on again begin again
let's have a little look at this that
was stylized back heel assist
oh very nice sweet that was great
okay see it's fine we can we can we can
afford a draw because we did so well in
our first two games okay that's not a
problem
i feel at ease yeah spain would you like
that
let's see if we can just steal this back
william no don't not with this character
james all right that works okay
yeah yeah just yeah we gotta be nice
he's gonna be dancing
bullying no wow okay yeah let's uh
let's get out of our defense you know
accidentally do the ball oh no
we did oh it's all right okay let's uh
bring it back
oh no no no no this is this is bad
oh you took too long dude no no dear
84th minute
that's all right i'm sure we've still
done enough
even if england have beaten hungary that
meant i wonder if we can can we see the
scores in the other games right now is
that a thing we can do
match facts no no no i think it's only
in the career mode
[Applause]
[Music]
well fingers crossed they haven't
recorded a historic nine-mil victory
over hungary or something
right we still we still have five
minutes of of this ultra
sped up time to go and score a goal so
that's one more chance
we got one one more chance oh what
we got me we had one more test
how very dare
i don't know this one
oh no yeah
you see it's excellent now you know how
it feels good
to have a golden slide shame on you yeah
exactly
nice okay
oh
it was a huge touch we got away with it
oh yeah come on oh
i'm i'm offside am i right oh no
no
[Music]
oh that should be there that was the
last kick of the game
but don't worry i think i think we're
still going through
i hope we are otherwise we'll have to do
something else
um let's find out advance what was the
hungary score
uh england oh i can see it there
um oh wait why are we playing them again
i don't know we not
are we playing everyone twice in the
group no surely not
really i'm sure i said that that was
that wouldn't happen
um yeah but we would be going through
though like we're still top of the group
which is good
um okay let me see why it's doing that
um yeah okay it's trying to do this
again i wonder if i can change
probably can't now we're in the
tournament oh that's annoying i would
thought i'd deliberately set this up
correctly but i might not have
um what we could do is we can actually
make a mini tournament all right here's
what we're going to do
okay we're going to engineer this
ourselves so it's going to actually be a
different tournament but we can use the
same teams
okay so the eight teams we need are
scotland and spain
you have to help me remember it okay
russia wales
portugal italy and france belgium
scotland's and spain
yeah so you remember you remember these
four and i'll remember the four
so scotland spain russia and wales yeah
i'll remember portugal italy
franz and belgium scotland spain russia
wales okay you've got this
in belgium i don't know i don't think
i've got this but well uh
portugal italy throughout belgium okay
now you're from scotland spain russia
wales
yeah we got it we got it i think we can
do it okay so what we're going to do i
guess
if anyone doesn't know how to do this
and people i can show you now so
we can go to tournaments um actually you
know what we should do let's
play let's play the finals tournament um
we've got women in the international so
i think can we do custom
oh i'm not sure if we can do custom
tournaments can we can we make it
women's team so let's find out
um i think the custom tournament is only
men's touch well what we can do is why
don't we just jump in
let's see what we can do women's
international cup so can you
play the lion load okay yeah let's uh
we got scotland through let's let's mix
it up then so would you want to play
is england plays england okay this time
might as well yeah that sounds good okay
cool and
how do i let's go done
okay um we've got germany's go i see i
have no idea
who who are the good teams other than
like england and america america's quite
good
yeah um who's that player that
transferred from
uh netherlands to the uk i
remember her name found something but
she was really good too
did you i was actually in america when
that when that world cup was on
very cool because yeah i was staying
with my cousin who
was essentially a professional soccer
player oh really when she was at
university yeah yeah
then she kind of gave it up but yeah it
was great to see the atmosphere over
there and like because they
they just love sports and even though
soccer is not that big
the in the american yeah compared yeah
it's amazing
all right so we're playing scotland now
okay now i need to
defeat your home can we bring you in at
this point
customize let's see what happens with
your customized site
yes there we go
great okay let's give it a go play match
now you can get some revenge as england
okay well you know
same ball though for some reason which
i'm fine with
every match i think this is the first
fifa where they've had women's football
i think
yes it is i think it's one of them don't
think it wasn't fever 20.
good i know about that yeah absolutely
[Applause]
nimble speed yeah these
these these they are really fast well
england
are one of the best teams in the world
aren't they yeah yeah women's yeah they
are
always football yeah they are oh almost
nice attempt the speed difference is
yeah it's crazy isn't it wow all right
love it in
i'm ready to head it oh
oh how did that make it through oh
where are you going where are you going
ah
come back
keepers easy nice and go through the c
okay right oh
[Applause]
nice nice oh you played advantage there
oh down the wing
lovely that's so so speedy have a shot
oh
good effort too safe are you double
tapping it i'm wondering if that's
something different yeah because you can
when i tap it sometimes it's got
less power well you can charge it as
well so you can hold maybe that'll
charge up a bit as well
yeah yeah that's how you but you don't
need to hold it for long otherwise it's
straight with the bar bully there you go
yeah scottish team
oh yes mine my ball got it i'm gonna
shoot
oh and i'm gonna miss by mile but you
see you get a little power bar though
yeah the bottom left underneath the name
yeah exactly
i think i wasn't holding it long enough
to see actually move
okay i just can't get over how like how
clear everything is
it's like you're watching and playing
much you know what i mean yeah
it's really great
i feel like every other time i've played
fifa there's always been that moment
when you're like i just can't quite see
the ball yeah
i mean that's why i bought my glasses
today but i actually think i need them
i'm being quite honest all right here we
go so i think after this we'll um we can
jump and have a look at some other modes
because it's actually
there's so much in fifa 21 i've not seen
there's like a vaulter mode which is
a kind of um fifa street kind of street
football kind of thing
um so you can check that out you can
always have a look at the kind of career
modes what i really
might really like about it as well in
career modes is if you like try to
transfer a player to your club it takes
you to this little animation
where your character the manager you've
made like isn't a fancy restaurant
chat i know chatting to the agent of the
other team and you're like
yeah so i'll buy ronaldo for 135 million
and then you have a little negotiation
it's quite fun
i like it yeah we can do that actually
we'll just start a career and then just
try and buy some players
yeah let's do it that's it it's like a
little mini game within the game
because if you go in too high and
they'll just they'll just get really
angry and leave
yeah really they're like how dare you
they leave the restaurant yeah
they just storm out yeah it's great
excuse me or if you offer
if you offer them too little and then if
the you if you they accept your
your offer for the player you then have
to negotiate a salary
for the player so then you sit down with
the player and their agent
no again and if they say oh how much
you're gonna play you're gonna pay my
player
and you say too little then the player
gets upset and they leave
the restaurant so it's really awesome i
love that
i did that detail it's quite fun it's
super cool yeah although when the game
first came out there was a strange bug
on ps4
where it just meant that you're all the
characters so
your manager and um like whoever the
agent was they were the same player
model this like
this random generic bold character
so i was like wait who's this guy and
why is he negotiating with this
identical twin
um why do you look alike yeah exactly
all right let's get
let's get a goal here and then we can
maybe
have a look at some other modes oh
nice terrible pass
just all the way up i do feel like
professional is probably the mode
for us because it's not that easy
anymore challenging yeah it is
challenging but i do think we can
definitely do it here we go
okay i'm looking for that pass nice oh
inside
oh oh nice come on yes
you just said it yeah well done awesome
take that scotland oh sorry
make myself feel bad
nice and then nice great
really nice is that beth beth mead
yeah she's an awesome player she is yeah
yeah
right i have time again we're very good
at doing this yeah
all right so let's dive in the second
half uh oh actually um now let's let's
maybe let's maybe
change things up we've seen quite a lot
of this the kind of standard mode now
we've seen some of the women's football
as well
yeah if i uh that we've proven we can
win in this mode
so let's try another for some reason
there we go
now let's go to uh
no i don't mean to do that it's not
restart match
that's the easiest way to get back to
the menu actually the easiest way is
just to jump to result
that'll sim the rest of the game okay no
more goals fine
and then we can quit from here so you
can sing the rest of the game so we
still won technically
yeah but then but it's not that when you
sim
um the the other team could win they
could come back and be alright
it's not like it doesn't keep that
result till the end of the game it just
simulates it
from that point okay so let's quit here
okay and if we okay so
vaulter football i have not played we
can also
there's also career mode this ultimate
team which doesn't really make sense to
do now that's more of a like
you get cards for different players yeah
and you can assemble a team that way
um you can just jump into champions
league um but
let's try let's try volta football
because i've never tried this
so let's see it's just we don't need to
be online
okay oh did that not
oh maybe we do need to be online i think
okay let's find out
why did they play offline um yeah i
don't know
uh okay select a player edit all the
details oh we can edit the player as
well well youtube you did say that
you go for it uh let's go for this dude
okay um all right we're gonna name our
guy
uh okay a quick one uh let's go for
i can never i can never think what to
name people i'm just gonna say damian
damien okay
do we have to give him a surname or can
he just be damien he's just going to be
okay is he english uh let's see
ah let's say el salvador
okay damian advance okay
i'll do oh wait i'll do that i think
i'll take
we can take it oh no i think i've just
advanced all the way
sorry i mean like advance to the next
oh sorry yeah you'll have to make damien
again i want to die i want to dive into
the
i love character creators it's so much
fun so do i i love this
but i spent so many hours hours in like
content i'm great
oh this is cool oh okay featured battles
i don't
who's that i don't know let's say oh
yeah
music okay uh well okay it's this is all
the tutorials we haven't done this
before
oh do we still have damien oh we do all
right fine let's let's just continue so
i don't know how this works so let's
just try
oh this one looks cool so i think it's
like um
five five sides i think yeah five e5
yeah yeah yeah
so uh yeah pick one um so we're playing
professional oh you've got an amateur oh
that's fine if we go we just go game
settings and let's just uh
i see you trying to make it easier uh oh
wait i think we can
actually can we can we go back yeah yeah
there we go let's go back to
professional
so you went from amateur to professional
and missed the semi-pro no no we were on
before yeah you did a really massive
jump later
so we play as team i think yeah
okay this is our this i think this is
our team here
this collection look at this setting
yeah this is cool
guy is ahead
okay is this us no this is there's
damian come on
come on the poses i love it
so i think this game is way more like
skill moves that are
uh kind of important in this oh good
that was oh no oh
good save oh that was quick
wait who am i oh are you in here
i'm here oh wait oh my god i'm like a
[Laughter]
do you want to do do you want to take a
team each
all right go and then let's go yeah
let's do this for a bit
ah okay fine fifa no fun
we'll play together he was like no fifa
says
negativity always collaboration
the thing is who's our team now
yeah that's a good point actually
because they're all wearing different
clothes come on damien
shoot no not bad that's right the goals
are obviously a lot smaller now yeah
exactly i'm slightly confused as well as
too
who is who yeah oh i got it oh no that
man
are the controls at the same actually so
i was trying to slide tackle oh there
they are yeah they are
oh no oh we conceded
on the plus side we tripped him up so
oh he's going to do a little celebration
there okay
oh yeah come on come on come on that was
oh
wow probably oh no
not in this game mate
oh i think this is going to be tricky
yeah i don't it's
i'm losing i'm definitely no no no you
you dig it i'm not i've got the ball
eat i don't i don't anymore oh hello
free kick it's free kick
yeah they just uh okay it's nelly
nelly on the ball shoots
[Applause]
yes there we go
all right we're coming back i want to
see our custom celebration what's he
gonna do
okay we get a little replay slow motion
replay
i do love this this is so cute yeah
isn't it that was cool
it reminds me of like not me because
obviously i didn't play football
but like this old school friend saying
from five side and everyone watching
yeah yeah it's nice different their
variation from there yeah so i remember
fifa street used to be
i remember this is basically fifa street
but then just rolled into fifa 21.
oh nice now um what should also mention
is uh
when remember i was talking about the um
the sound earlier and how it kind of
tracks for the action
we're also as well as the tv speakers
we're using
soundbar which you can see in front of
the tv there okay yeah
and that is the q 900t soundbar
and we've got the volume turned down a
little bit right now because of the
stream but it sounds
amazing especially when you get the roar
of the crowd as you were playing earlier
mm-hmm
it was really cool so it travels around
yeah well that's with the um
with that kind of sound feature as part
of the tv yeah because it means we get
the sound at the tv
and also out of the sound bar it's
really hard to talk and pass the ball
sorry
i'm hogging the ball entirely oh nice
oh nearly off the post yeah it was so
close
um yes sorry as i was that was the
object tracking sound i was describing
oh no
okay so you have the sound bar object
tracking sound yeah so the well
so the tv is doing the object tracking
sound but because
this is kind of a rare thing is they
work together
with the soundbar and the tv so you get
sound at both so it's not like as soon
as you plug the soundbar in the tv stops
it's all together oh good effort
that's awesome come on come on come on
no
so that was a save i still haven't
figured out the names of all our team we
i know we have damien
we have nelly one damien you're a star
player here we go
oh all right gonna do a little corner
here
uh yeah come in
lucky come on nelly let's go
[Music]
i think we've got someone named digger
[Applause]
oh street fighter favor yeah i think we
lost we did
oh it's halftime okay there's two halves
i wasn't sure there
okay do we have other players let's have
a look
is our squad called j10 i don't think we
do i think that is just our squad
you're tired it doesn't matter i suppose
if you play with your mates in the park
you don't have
subs dude
oh good effort
oh come on listen
[Applause]
[Music]
come on buddy you're our star player get
your head in the game damian come on
she says controlling him jamie on the
ball
in your face so mean
all right oh it's it's a it's not
through it's a little pass
[Applause]
i remember in school like the goalkeeper
would be holding on to the one people
would still be
kicking me oh gosh remember that nobody
ever wanted to be keeper
right yeah because you really got
bullied yes i just take turns be like oh
fine i guess i'm keeper
oh nelly's in space all right you've
you're in space oh
oh come on
[Applause]
i can never find our player again i'm
like i know how many which ones you need
oh no three one oh jad
you've been being hammered now how are
we doing better in the profession i
don't know
in the street football all right here we
go this is serious now
come on uh oh come on got this we've got
we've got this come on no blocks again
no oh god damn it no
don't you score you're not better
oh dear so maybe i was a bit
excitable when i put us on
professionally for a moment we've never
played before
that should have been a good pass yeah
i'm not sure
why that happened yeah i don't know
where am i looking oh see our keeper has
done this
i've done a very good job of this game
okay
nice
that's better getting some possession of
easter
concentrating he says possession he says
and then
he gives it straight to the opposition
[Applause]
[Music]
he has been practicing that celebration
for weeks yeah i know
well he has kind of earned it seeing as
it's 5-1 oh i think that's game over
oh dear oh oh wow
skills i think he's just showing off
all right ricardo we get it we get it
you're good at football right hold on
okay so um let's uh let's quickly try
um another mode as well just at the end
did you want to try the um yeah the
restaurant scene i want
to do the restaurant yes i'll show you
yeah so if we
let me just quickly quit this quickly
um how do i do that
i don't actually know because i've never
played volta before i'm like how do i
get out of this there we go right
so uh you can do career mode okay career
mode we'll do this very very quickly
uh use current squads that's fine um
manage your career
you can choose your manager i like her
hats she can be armed i do like the hat
yeah a a manager
okay and then you can get into the game
and then what you can do
is you can buy players um and i just
want to show you the restaurant scene
so we can witness it on the giant tv
but it does take a wee minute to well
actually not that long to kind of build
the
career like um all the teams and
everything um
skip the pre-season okay so what you do
is you go over your transfers
and um well you can either search for
players or
you can buy players who you kind of
scout for
so there's already three this is
tutorials
three players it's kind of like
recommending so let's say you want to
buy jamie vardy
from who famously plays for leicester
city he's at the end of his career but
he's still a very good player
arsenal want to buy him okay so uh
shortlist and transfer hub now we go
over to our transfer hub
it's over here and we uh
i know how to do this game and then we
go approach to buy
okay and we enter the restaurant scene
complete with cowboy hats good to see
you you've been looking forward to
sitting down where they
make it start exactly they have a little
chat um
she and irish cowboy i like that and you
can be like all right um
so what do you want to offer for jamie
vardy
so we can see we've got 87 we've got 87
million to spend geez
and he's valued at 49. let's give maybe
a 60 million
60. yeah no i mean his value is 49.
i know but don't you want to encourage
him to leave well this is
this will encourage him this is just the
money we're going to get to the club you
know we're purchasing him from the club
then we need to
let's just 50. 50. all right yeah yeah
50 million okay
50 million there we go i wish that was
worth 50 50. i know it's crazy isn't it
and you can go submit offer we're ready
to offer you
50 million for party okay let's see what
happens
well she's really taking your time just
to say this yeah you know there wasn't
that many words
look oh your offer for barty isn't good
enough
i think we consider 75. i did say 16.
yeah you did i'm sorry i'm sorry
now we've hurt his feelings okay okay
right so
well counter 60 let's do something okay
okay okay
transfer fee 70 so it goes to which
it goes to what he just suggested so
there you go 65 oh sorry 60 on the nose
and bads and he's like
we could be agreed to 60. imagine you
just go to a restaurant and it's
about 60 million i know crazy
it looks like a nice place though mm-hmm
the music's quite nice yeah
also it's up in something oh wow
price is non-negotiable so we've got to
go for 75. that seems like a lot for a
player who's uh 33.
um but we don't have to i mean he says
no because i'm not being naked
he's just you know he's at the end he's
at the end of his career great player
but
so let's i bet if we go 70 and we say
i bet i bet i'll never really upset him
maybe
let's see there you go you see he lied
he was like there's nothing questionable
oh wait except it is
little handshake and there you go 70
million for vardy
okay i don't know what the animal fans
watching make of this purchase
and then we go to jimmy vardy and we say
all right jamie vardy
let's have a chat we're in the same
clothes exactly
now one of the things i realized i
haven't actually mentioned while we're
playing fifa
about um about the samsung q800t while
we watch these guys have a lovely
dinner is that it's got something called
um
game mode enhancer plus and that means
when you when you plug in a console to
this tv and you put the game mode on it
actually enables a whole load of
functions
not just the usual game mode that you
might be used to yeah
so it's a whole bunch of things it's
like the usual low input lag that we
know from gaming which would like fifa
is obviously really important because if
you've got a delay between
passing and a pass happening but it's a
bunch of other things as well
um like variable refresh rate so i'm
just going to do this at the same time
important please yeah so if we're
playing fifa and the xbox having a hard
time maybe
because there's a whole load of action
going on the frame rate dips
the tv's refresh rate will actually
match that so we won't see things like
screen tearing
oh cool yeah so there's a whole load of
functionality it's part of that gaming
game enhancer plus and the great thing
is you just have to
turn it on and then it's all there you
don't need to enable
go through all the menus and enable all
these things sounds so
it's like easy yeah exactly and you just
i just like to know when i'm
sitting down and playing game on a tv
that the settings are the
the optimal for what yeah cause i'll
just be annoyed if i think i've played a
game and actually i didn't have it set
up right
um so yeah it just takes that takes that
anxiety away it just sets you up for
this journey next year and probably this
tv really exactly
oh yeah i mean well we do we know that
current this because obviously the
series x we know it's capable of 8k but
obviously it's not
doing it yet but when it does well
yeah this you're good because this tv
can do 8k
so yeah it is it's definitely future
proofed
and speaking of the future i think we'll
have you here for two years barty
and no release cause now finally the
money question
whoa he wants five million when he
scores 20 goals
i mean 20 goals that's i mean that's
if you can guarantee 20 goals i mean i
can't even score one so
but there you go that's uh that's the
restaurant scene and cool
i love that so i think that's probably
as much time as we got for fifa today
but i want to know jan
yeah what's your what's your thoughts on
fifa after staying you enjoy i've
actually enjoyed it
i've really had fun i think when i try
to play fifa by myself it's probably
i'm missing that camaraderie that
teamwork i think that's how i'd like to
play moving forward so i also think
you've had the kind of ultimate fifa
experience playing on this
huge tv like it's definitely the best
way best way to play
um but yeah so uh i think that's pretty
much all we have time for on the stream
today thank you very much for watching
everybody and in fact if you watched all
three of the streams
that's really appreciated i think we've
had a really good
experience of combining the samsung
q800t with the xbox series x
um and so make sure if you want more
information about any of the
products we've talked about the tv the
soundbar just go the link in the
description
all the information is right there and
uh yeah jan just thank you very much
for joining me for these three streams
it's been really good
and i hope to see you become a fifa pro
and uh yeah tell me
next year i'll be ready next year okay
and uh thanks everyone for
watching and uh make sure you stay tuned
to gainspot for more of fifa
and everything else
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you